caitlyn jenner opens up about the  current status of her relationship with  the kardashians  many very opinionated women  on monday's good morning britain the 67  year old olympian got candid about her  extended family  revealing she spends plenty of time with  daughters kylie and kendall jenner  but when it comes to step-daughter kim  kardashian  kim i haven't talked to in six nine  months it's a big  loss in my life not having her there  anymore  it was really tough for me kim also  recently opened up about caitlyn while  co-hosting live with kelly and ryan  i feel like there's been so much like  hurt and pain with  caitlyn and my mom and at the end of the  day like i'll always ride for my mom  but admitted there could still be hope  for a reconciliation  you know we're family so i do believe  that maybe this is just a phase  [Music]